so that I'm like so anti- interval
invent interventionalist but uh then
sometimes people just get attacked
sometimes your country gets invaded and
I've never lived that life because I'm
from the United States in the late 90s
you know where we never got invaded But
now sometimes it it just sometimes it
can happen and you got to be realistic
about that there's no time to Waffle if
your country is under attack you can't
let the a hot air balloon float all the
way across your landmass like you split
second decision balloon that we did let
float Across America yeah asinine and
the was like wait there's something here
and we were just like who knows we'll
just see what happens oh wait we shot it
down later I mean I I get you know the
desire to sort of feel like you you need
to act right but in in this case you
have to go back to like our government
is to serve the American people and what
is ultimately the best interest of the
American people I can understand an
argument for we have allies we've made
agreements we've made deals but you know
I think the president has the duty to
the American people first and we can't
forget that